good morning believe nation today's
messages Wow I'm sorry what was the
message
so the question day today is good
morning believe nation today's message
is studied the business over to you Ross
Perot my advice to person who's
considering starting a small business is
number one
serve an apprenticeship in an industry
you're really excited about let's assume
you have a master's degree in business
from Harvard go to work second and third
shift on the factory floor learned it
from the bottom up really know that
business work there a few years insist
on doing every job and one of these days
the light is going on in your head and
you're going to have a really unorthodox
idea an unmet need the way you find it
is by burying yourself in an industry
you adore that's the way you identify
the unmet need and then you have the
germ of the idea to start your own
company so what do you think you know
what before I got into the career of
dancing running the dance school I want
it to be a marriage counselor so I went
into psychology I started getting my
education by working on my bachelor's
through it I realized that it wasn't for
me then I changed career paths I wanted
to be a police officer I became a
security guard to see what the nightlife
nightshift life dealing with people who
are not necessarily always happy how was
that I realized that that wasn't for me
in each of these career choices I went
into the field to see what it's like to
experience some part of it and figure
out if it's right for me with TDS of
Toronto dance salsa it was the same
thing I started as a student I went to
become a helper assistant I became
instructor when I had the opportunity to
run basically the
I realized that it was for me because of
all the experience that I had to see
what it's like and the environment and I
loved the environment so why would I
want to be some warehouse so absolutely
I connect with them if you want to go
into a different energy if you want to
start your own business
see what it's like see what kind of
experience you can get work for someone
else if you want to be a lawyer and you
want to open up your own business work
for a law firm figure out if that's the
kind of environment you want to have and
then from there you can figure out you
want to open up your own law firm yeah
I've always been a big believer that you
shouldn't just jump fooling on a
business go work for somebody who's done
what you want to do work for a company
that has 10 employees or less in the
industry that you want to be in and go
work for them you're getting paid to
learn you're getting paid to make
mistakes you're getting paid to get
connections in the industry normally you
pay to go to school here you're getting
paid to do it and you're gonna make all
the mistakes on somebody else's dime and
then when you're ready to start your own
company you have the connections you
have the experience one of the reasons
why I know so much more about
entrepreneurship is after I sold my
first business I only had one company it
was a biotech software company when I
sold it
I joined their venture capital company
and was these guys were in their 60s or
70s and I was this young heart kid
joining them and they taught me a lot
about all sorts of different businesses
you know every day we had new companies
coming in and I was able to kind of
leech off of their decades of collective
experience to learn how different
industries are run and it got me there
so much faster than if I was just trying
to do everything myself so I love the
idea of if you're just starting up but
you want to get into business you could
start your business on the side but go
work for a company that you respect and
look up to that you want to be like in a
couple years
learn as much as you can from them and
when you have enough money from your own
thing that you can afford to quit your
job and go do that full-time that's when
you make the move so the question of the
day today is would you be willing to
take a pay cut to work for someone who's
the expert in the industry that you're
thinking of breaking into and why I like
it leave it in the comments below we
will join in the discussion also finally
when they give a quick shout-out to
Jafra Leap Delisle thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book here one
word I really really really appreciate
it
I hope you enjoyed them so thank you
guys again for watching we believe in
you we hope you continue to believe in
yourself I'm wrong wait both believe in
yourself and whatever you're one where
it is much love and we'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot of
espresso if you want to be successful in
starting a business then you study what
people have learned and everything that
people have learned that written down or
shared in seminars or put onto audio
programs is I learned this from a very
wise man named cop cop Meyer who spent
more than 50 years studying success and
he had developed more than 1,000 success
principles that he had derived out of
something like 6,000 books and when I
met him I asked him the question you
would ask of all these thousand
principles because I've studied it all
which is the most important principle of
all and he said Brian he said it's
simple he said use proven success
methods he said learn from the experts
he said Brian you'll never live long
enough to learn it all for yourself so
what I find is that successful people
are those who learn from others who have
gone before them unsuccessful people try
to make it all up like a cook going into
the kitchen taking ingredients out of
the cupboards throwing them all in a
bowl and wondering why it doesn't taste
good this is why people sales careers
why 80% of sales people are functioning
well below their potential only 20% make
all the money by 20% of businesses in
any industry make all the profits by 20%
of the professionals in any service make
80% of the money and so on is because
they follow proven success principles
proven recipes proven formulas proven
combinations and they just do them over
and over again until they master them
then they can do the more and more of
them faster and faster easier and easier
at a higher level of quality have all
that translates into greater results did
not have the Rich Dad in your life what
would you be doing today
that's hard to say if it didn't have my
Rich Dad because as a young kid
probably about the age of five six seven
eight nine I really wanted to be rich so
I think number one is desire you know
and then you naturally seek your role
models and teachers and in my lifetime
I've had multiple rich debts you know my
rich dad was my best friend's father's
during the age of nine and then today I
still seek mentors and wise men and wise
women because that's how you get wiser
is by hanging out with smart people